- I see my patients repeating
these skincare mistakes all the time.
And I've spoken to plenty of
my dermatologist colleagues
and we agree, this is the top list.
Let's get started, but before
we do, a huge thank you
to my long-term partner, Murad,
for sponsoring this video.
Popping those good old pimples.
As a general rule, you should
not pop your own pimples.
If you do attempt to pop a pimple
and ended up breaking your skin barrier,
you risk permanent acne scarring.
If your pimple contains infected pus,
popping can spread bacteria
into other pores, hair follicles
and create even a worse outbreak.
In fact, popping a
pimple can actually delay
your body's natural healing process.
This is where spa
treatments come in handy.
Pouring on hydrogen peroxide and alcohol.
Despite what we've been told as kids,
using hydrogen peroxide or rubbing alcohol
to clean an injury can
actually harm the tissue
and delay healing.
The best way to clean a minor wound
is with cool, running water and mild soap.
Rinse the wound for at least five minutes
to remove dirt, debris and bacteria.
Wounds, however, that are large, deep
or bleeding nonstop should
be treated by a professional,
you know, one with scrubs like this.
Shaving hard.
When it comes to how hard
you should be pressing
the razorblade down on your skin,
always remember, less is more.
The harder you push down,
the more uneven the skin surface becomes
because the skin begins to dimple,
and companies have tried to compensate
for this common tendency,
making razors that
resist shaving pressure,
but you will still get
a great nick-free shave
if you use that light touch.
Keeping wet clothes on for too long.
I'm talking about the rain, the pool,
the gym, whatever it is.
Wet and sweaty clothing can trap dust
and dirt that clogs pores
and often leads to breakouts.
Cotton is great at absorbing water,
therefore deflecting body oil,
but all this high-tech performance gear
that we're wearing
actually deflects water,
that's why it's moisture-wicking.
However, it also absorbs body oils
and then the bacteria
feed on those body oils
and release a really gross scent.
On top of it, you put yourself
at higher risk for jock itch
and other fungal infections,
which is no fun for your skin.
Falling for social media fads.
TikTok and social media
in general is loaded
with skincare knowledge like this.
(buzzer buzzing)
And this.
- I look good
with this kitty litter on my face.
- But it's important to remember
that miracle cures don't exist,
and some of the hacks we
see online are complete BS.
Also, do not assume
what works for a friend
or celeb will work for you.
Everyone has unique skincare
needs, issues and goals.
And it's probably important to add
that there's a lot of surgery
and Photoshopping at play online.
Taking long, hot showers.
Hot showers are no bueno for your skin.
They might be good for
your soul, but ideally,
you should try and keep your
showers on the shorter side.
And if you enjoy hot water,
you should keep it even shorter
as that hot water can
strip the body of oils
and dry out your skin.
For my patients with eczema-prone skin,
hot water actually draws
moisture away from the skin.
And while it may feel good initially,
frequent exposure can actually
exacerbate that eczema.
Keeping small cuts and wounds covered.
So many of my patients
believe the best way
to let a minor wound heal
is by letting it dry out.
Actually, keeping it covered
and allowing it to stay
moist has been shown
to heal better with a
healthier layer of new skin,
AKA, less visible scarring.
But if you do have an annoying scar,
Murad's InvisiScar Resurfacing
Treatment is a great grab
for pitted scars as it
has been clinically proven
to minimize the look of scar size,
depth, texture and discoloration.
Forgetting that skin is its own organ.
The skin needs to be looked after
just like all the other
organs in our bodies.
Consider getting regular skin exams
especially if you have a family
history, use tanning beds,
or had many sunburns in the past.
Knowing what's normal for you
is incredibly important as well.
So if you see a mold
change or a new one appear,
that's definitely worth
a visit to your doctor.
No shade, no sunblock.
You really need sunscreen every day.
Yes, even when it's cloudy,
raining, or snowing.
Ever go skiing and not wear sunblock?
- [Crowd] Ouch!
- Sun exposure causes
sunspots, skin damage,
and even lead to skin cancer.
Using a simple daily
moisturizer/sunscreen combo is best
but make sure it's at least 30 SPF.
And don't forget to apply
it to the ears and lips
as they're the most commonly missed areas.
Skipping the good old neck.
If your skincare routine
stops at your jawline,
you're doing it wrong.
Your neck needs some love too.
In fact, the neck is one of
the first areas of the body
to show signs of aging
because the skin is
thinner than on your face.
Also staring at our cell phones
with our necks bent all the
time isn't doing us any favors.
Ever-changing routines
and too many products.
As fun as it can be to
try new skincare products,
doing so too frequently can create
more questions and problems.
Most ingredients will take
at least four to six weeks
of consistent use before
noticeable changes.
Also, know that if you
have a negative reaction,
it's gonna be really hard
to pinpoint the cause
if you introduce two to three
products simultaneously.
Over-exfoliate with harsh scrubs.
While exfoliation is
important in moderation,
it's easy to overdo it
with exfoliating scrubs,
especially when your skin is feeling dry.
Overdoing it can cause
tiny tears in the skin,
leading to the development
of a rash-like texture
and uneven tone, like
patchy, red blotches.
Breakouts are another common reaction,
especially small, rough, bumpy pimples.
If you're using a scrub on your face,
you should do it max two times per week.
And when you're doing
it, please be gentle.
Don't scrub your skin raw.
Picking their skin.
You may not even realize that you do it,
but constantly picking at the
skin can cause irritation,
inflamed skin and spread bacteria.
The digits or our fingers
are the dirtiest parts
of our bodies and harbor
all sorts of bacteria
that should stay on the
outside of our skin.
If this is a nervous
habit, try to break it
by keeping your hands
busy with something else
or perhaps asking for others
to help point out when you're doing it
without even knowing it.
Fearing thy moisturizer.
Skin is meant to keep bad
things out of your body,
and moisturizing is imperative
for a healthy skin barrier,
which is why you shouldn't skip out
on using moisturizers daily.
Many of my patients with oily
or acne-prone skin think they
should use this product less,
but the reality is,
they should just find the
right product for them.
In fact, for me, I have
acne-prone skin, as you can tell,
and I've battled it on and
off for quite some time.
Lately though, I found some great success
with Murad's Acne Control lines,
specifically the Clarifying Cleanser.
While I try not to use
salycilic products daily,
I find that when I'm going
through a problematic acne phase,
using that gel cleanser
that contains green tea
extract for irritation,
I get great results.
I challenged Hyram to see if he knew skin.
Click here to check that out,
and as always, stay happy and healthy.
And again, huge thank you to Murad
for sponsoring this video.
(upbeat music)